[Music]
i'm sure all of you patriots spent your
weekend like i did celebrating july 4th
ringing in america's birthday
you fire up the grill toss a few dogs on
if you know anything about hot dogs
they're thumins
you crack open a cold one and breathe in
the smoky smell of meat or maybe
something else if you're greg gutfelt
like joey chestnut who man handled the
enemy while demolishing 63 dogs to win
the annual nathan's hot dog eating
contest
that is america at its finest
and that is also peak athletic ability
or if you're just a kid you played a
little baseball under the lights
[Music]
and those who served our country can
recollect upon the sacrifices that have
been made which brings a tear to their
eyes
people don't realize what they have
they [ __ ] about it
and then nowadays
i am so upset
that the things we did and the things we
fought for and the boys that died for it
it's all gone down the drain
our country's gone to hell that's not
what our boy that's not what they died
for
young and old we all get to wear our
patriotism with pride on independence
day which year long as parades go by and
we honor and salute soldiers past and
present who risk their lives to defend
our freedoms so on america's birthday we
need to show the old girl some love and
give our country the party it deserves
unfortunately for us our president had
different ideas
now i don't know how biden family
parties go
but it waters family functions we try to
keep the drug and sex addicts under
federal investigation at arm's length
but that wasn't the case at the white
house where joe biden figured july 4th
was the perfect time to shove hunter
biden down our throats and i apologize
for that analogy
joe is just flaunting his family's
crimes at this point
take a page at a queen elizabeth's book
and give hunter the prince andrew
treatment
the queen kicked andrew to the curb
after his ties to epstein came to light
and the prince was accused of sleeping
with a minor she stripped the prince of
all of his royal duties and banished him
to the back of the castle
that's what matriarchs or patriarchs do
out of respect for the title they hold
but andrew's got nothing on hunter drugs
illegal guns bribes corruption but hey
at least he's nice to russian escorts
is anything hurt on you
anything
i was
literally saying i'm sorry that it took
so long to give you ten thousand dollars
have i ever touched you in a bad way
ever have i asked you every time if i
could touch you
every time
screener look at me
you cannot talk to me that way
and say things like that
because i'm more respectful than anyone
you've ever met
that's who joe biden brought to the
people's house to celebrate america's
birthday
that guy
i don't want him in my shindig i've seen
what he does to m m's
and does everything have to be written
on a note card for joe biden apparently
they forgot to write you say god bless
america on july 4th
thank you all so very very much thanks
okay and
god bless america thank you
that's like showing up at a friend's
party and forgetting the words to happy
birthday
maybe instead of no cards they should
just show biden movies of how real
presidents conduct themselves
we will not go quietly into the night
we will not vanish without a fight
we're going to live on
we're going to survive
today
we celebrate our independence day
all-time great moment in movie history
but something like that would never be
written today because hollywood really
doesn't like america
and of course the left used our
country's birthday to pile on
i just feel like i need to say this
you know i would say happy fourth of
july but
it's not really a happy fourth of july
is it this ain't the land of the free
listen to the star-spangled burner and
all of that and i go this is not the
land of the freed so it's hard for me to
say happy fourth of july because it
feels like we're going back to slavery
you know so maybe i should say happy
back to slavery day
usually when you celebrate someone's
birthday you don't rip them to shreds
while they're blowing out the candles
and if you're at a party you don't want
to get between michael moore and a
birthday cake
probably the most dangerous place on
earth
the filmmaker has said he will no longer
accept full citizenship privileges
following the road decision
one i didn't know that anybody would
actually sleep with michael moore and
make roe v wade an issue
and two
i didn't think you could pick and choose
which citizenship privileges you could
exercise
is it like a buffet you can have a
little of this and little of that
but moore promised to keep beating this
topic into the ground saying quote until
women's rights have been fully
reinstated
i will not shut up about this if you
invite me to dinner that's all i'm going
to talk about have me over to your party
and it's going to be dobs dobs and more
dobs
no one would be able to afford to invite
michael moore over to dinner with food
prices the way they are
so it's a moot point
bette midler tweeted out that july 4 was
cancelled due to a shortage of
independence
who does she think she is michael scott
like everybody's attention
christmas is cancelled you can't cancel
a holiday give it up stanley and you
will lose new year's what does that mean
jim take new year's away from stanley
sorry bet i didn't know celebrities
could cancel a holiday in that case
i'm canceling black friday
i'm just trying to save lives
every celebrity got in on the action it
was like a memo went out or something
here's samantha bee who we didn't even
know still had a show
it's not just about voting in november
it's about doing everything in our power
to protect and help vulnerable people
access abortion across state lines and
we have to raise hell in our cities in
washington in every restaurant justice
alito eats at for the rest of his life
because if republicans have made our
lives hell it's time to return the favor
so the white maxine waters wants to get
in people's faces where justice alito
eats
and since we can assume that alito likes
italian food good luck enjoying your
rigatoni bolognese and a nice chianti in
the dc area
samantha is going to unleash the beehive
on you
if shutting down restaurants isn't your
thing maybe trampling police cars is
because that's what they did to
celebrate america's independence in
chicago
[Applause]
that's just not how you behave chicago
it's america's birthday and you're
acting like the drunk uncle
we're not mad we're just disappointed
and it only got worse in the windy city
as the weekend went on people can't even
attend a holiday parade without fearing
for their lives
as yesterday a deranged freak opened
fire on innocent civilians
22 year old robert crimo took position
on a rooftop overlooking the route and
carried out his sadistic attack killing
at least seven people and wounding two
dozen others
the guy was suicidal homicidal had
problems at school had a social media
footprint that screamed mass shooter
police had seized weapons from his house
including swords and guns and officials
in illinois still didn't stuff this kid
into a straitjacket
anyone with facial tattoos and a track
record like that is
screaming please put me in an insane
asylum
but the left saw all of this and decided
they wanted to take guns away from law
abiding gun owners
and remember the second amendment as the
supreme court just ruled is a uniquely
american right and is fundamental to who
we are
american principles are hard to
understand because
even the sight of the flag scares the
left
i was on long island this weekend uh
visiting a really dear friend and i was
really disturbed i saw you know dozens
and dozens of pickup trucks with uh you
know uh explicatives against joe biden
uh on the back of them uh trump flags
and some cases just dozens of american
flags which you know
is also just disturbing because
essentially the message was clear it was
this is my country this is not your
country
i own this
remember that one from last year
because we respect the country and know
how to behave on someone's birthday
we didn't
give the birthday boy double middle
fingers like this hollywood actress
we have better etiquette than that
and we let off fireworks at the beach
like normal people do
[Music]
[Applause]
that was hairy patis on the fuse
i need my microphone hand i mean i can't
blow it off like jason pierre paul
by the way as you know i put out a call
to arms last month
in desperate need of fireworks since new
york state considers them illegal
and my call was answered a patriot
stepped up
drove across state lines and secured a
considerable amount of commercial-grade
fireworks for the waters family
and that patriot is prime time's very
own
joey munez thank you joey
you are the man
so that's how normal people celebrate
july 4th we don't renounce our
citizenship shoot people attack cops or
invite hunter biden over
you learn a lot about someone by the way
they celebrate july 4th
and don't be this guy
[Music]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else